there is a some of the slides have some
code on them so it might be hard to read
on on the on the slides appear so you
can download a link there's a dropbox
link on the twitter page for the PI data
conference if you want to download that
especially in the back you might be
having a better time I've seen it well
thanks for the opportunity to come talk
to you today this is really the story of
a journey my journey kind of in
translating from c2 to using Python this
is the slide is is meant to give a
context of kind of where I come from
because I think that's really important
especially when you're trying to shift
to a new language or new learn a new
language I mean you're really influenced
by where you which language you learn
first and how you think about
programming and how you write the code
that you write as you see here I was fed
a healthy dose of structured programming
Pascal and C and a little bit of
object-oriented C++ and Java but I came
to programming not directly through
computer science but a little bit
different way so after spending several
years at my my first real job at
Fermilab as an embedded programmer I was
writing software for the accelerators
the particle accelerators there they
Fermilab to shut the Tevatron down and
then I moved to a new company my code
had nothing to do with that to have a
tron shutting down thank you so this is
f is IQ which is used to be VG bio and
now it's physique you are this is our
data pipeline just give you a context of
what we do this hoop this will be
popping up here and there we collect
data remotely from patients wearing
wearable devices we have a phone app
which translates that into binary data
and uploads it to our servers and we
extract the binary data into bio signals
and calculate those from those bio
signals like ECG PBG bio bioimpedance we
calculate vital signs respiration rate
heart rate these sorts of things and
then from those vital signs we use some
machine learning algorithms to estimate
so or predict sorry shouldn't use
predict estimate
vital signs and we store all this data
in a database which can be viewed I'm
going to be talking primarily first my
first job at when I went to physic you
was to translate the machine learning
algorithms the bottom level of that all
of this in the middle all of that cloud
server software is is the stuff i
implemented in Python or is currently
implemented in Python and the machine
learning larry was the first thing I
have worked on so the first task was to
convert that and there are lots of
matrix manipulations lots of matrix
algebra and here's our criterion for
success when our first attempt was Java
we we wanted a compiled language because
we were convinced it would be faster
we're also doing some other development
in Java specifically on our phone app
and so I went after it got the code
working in six weeks some of that time
was spent really understanding the
machine learning algorithms so it's not
a it wasn't all work we're getting java
in six weeks but it felt really heavy it
was really difficult job was not a
language you really want to do a lot of
matrix algebra in or any numerical
computations so my my supervisor at the
time said I gave me a little
dispensation that says try this in
Python and see if you can get it to work
see if it's possible we have the same
criterion for success and the results
weren't encouraging at the first I did
get it working in a day so that was nice
but it was seven times slower than java
the java implementation well i really
didn't want to go back to doing java so
it was time to optimize now knuth has
said that premature optimization is the
root of all evil and since i had only
spent a day I was kind of in that
premature pays but I really really
didn't want to do java so I went and I
profiled things and I looked at where
the culprit was it turned out that it
was in a very small function only about
10 lines of code without even with
comments and it's very simple but it was
called many many many many times so
thousands of times
and since it was simple i thought oh
this is going to be easy to optimize it
should be a problem at all so on the
Left I have this is my implementation
that is my first first pass at it and
almost a direct translation from the
Java and its really finding the minimum
and maximum between a row of an array
and another matrix column by column so i
use a list comprehension in those first
two lines after the comet and that's
because python all the python book says
that say that list comprehensions are
fast so i use a list comprehension well
that baseline execution that's the same
thing it was 596 microseconds which
doesn't seem to slow but when you start
executing it many many thousands of
times it's really slows down your
application when it doesn't need to so I
needed those yellow lines they're the
ones that were causing the problems so I
tried to fix it what what what do I do
okay the first thing I do I go back home
to what I've learned as I try a loop
loops are fast and see let's try a loop
well that was a spectacular failure that
didn't work at all and it was it was
about the same speed so I keep going try
another attempt to try another attempt
to try another attempt and nothing's
working so I'm trying to get starting to
get really nervous and thinking I'm
going to have to do Java for the rest of
my life but there are two problems with
this work first it was a shotgun
approach it's something I did I'm sure
none of you do that when you code but
and the second real big problem was that
I step back and I looked at it and I was
really thinking about this whole problem
as a see programmer and see all you have
our loops so that's what you do is loops
but Engine Python you have something you
have different things that you can do so
although I'm ashamed to admit it I felt
like it was time finally to go read the
manual so I went to the numpy manual and
I learned about broadcasting this is
taken directly from the numpy manual and
broadcasting allows you to vectorize
your loops so you can write code in such
a way that it doesn't look like a loop
but numpy converts it into a loop that
execute at sea level which makes it very
fast and it also really cleans up your
code so here's the original code those
lines not the whole function and that's
the average again and when i use
broadcasting this is what i get i get a
18 micro second a 33-percent speed hour
33 time speed up and i convert those
four lines to not much savings in code
lines but it's much more readable and
understandable it just says I want the
minimum between this row and this matrix
you don't even have to tell it you have
a row in a matrix numpy just figures
that out okay broadcasting can't be used
everywhere there's the it has to be used
in certain places if applicable so but
it worked for me and this was plenty
speed up for what I needed okay so the
next that was a really instructive thing
I and made me like Python even more it
was an expressive way of telling the
computer what I wanted it to do and it
was all so fast so the next time I think
I took a one step forward in my thing to
python but now I had to go back and
implement some algorithms that extracted
the bio signals and converted those two
vital signs well this is our level over
our pipeline so our task was to
implement these set of algorithms to
calculate vital signs what are our
concerns well there's signal variability
obviously and the first attempt was for
various things we wanted to do it on the
phone we thought we'd leverage the phone
we had a good phone developer and so we
decided to go with a C library that did
some of the algorithms which I was
responsible for integrate that into a
Java app run all the feature
calculations on the phone upload those
to a server and be done with it well
that gave us a very complex system that
was difficult to test and very very hard
to go from a new concept of algorithm or
a change concept of the algorithm to
test and development on the phone so
what we try to decided to do is to take
all those calculations that we were
doing on the phone and put them on the
server and so we're right back in the
realm of Python we want to implement all
the other ISM
algorithms in Python and get rid of that
C library and anything that does done on
the phone so we it allows us to have a
greater range of algorithms we can also
it's not totally real time but it's
pretty close so we're not and it's not a
requirement that we have actual real
time features so the three main tasks in
calculating vitals are you have to first
extract the source data then you pre
process it and you apply filter
algorithms now all the baselines are C
so our first extraction what does the
data look like looks like a binary
stream this is the data we had we had a
very kind hardware engineer who had
packets of data that were three bites
one bite was the ID of the signal and
the second two bites were the value and
these were all put out chronologically
in time so you can sort out which signal
came out at what time and you could
start out when they came well how do you
get those out in Python if you're ever
doing with Python data is binary you use
struct it's the standard thing so here's
a little function that I wrote to do
that it worked fairly well it did take a
while to execute the converting to the
numpy array takes a while and it's
getting a large amount of data out is
fine but this creates an n by 2 array
can we go faster yeah you can turns out
you can use numpy from file to do the
same operation and you get a 45 times
speed up and as an extra bonus you save
a line of code but the data still
interleaved you have n by 2 you have all
these p these ids and values ID and
values how do you get the out I'd like
to collate that data by signal level
well numpy again provides some nice
masking features where you can just go
and do what's called I guess fancy
indexing if I'm using the term right you
can get good mask off all the signals
are related to one signal and quickly
pull all of those out into their own
data set so again this code on the right
bottom right is very expressive it tells
us shows exactly what I'm doing
and it's very fast okay now we have the
bio signals from the binary data but we
need good data now Babbage reminds us
that you can't put in bad data and good
good results so we need good data so
we've extracted those bio signals and
now we have to calculate the vital signs
and with good data how do we get good
data well when you look at the world
real data is very very messy all right
you've got electrical noise you've got
all kinds of things that that can
influence the signal all right some
things you have control over you can
control the electrical noise you can
make your hardware good but there are
other things you can't control these are
wearable devices people are wearing
these devices and and they do annoying
things like they get up and they move
around and they jiggle the device and
they cough and they do all kinds of
things that mess up the signals that
you're trying to work with but so you
have to deal with that what are the
tools in their toolbox well we have
filters we go way back to signal
processing any electrical engineers in
the room yeah you can kind of you can go
to sleep for the next slide you have
filters these are different kinds of
filters you have convolution FFF TS and
you could down sample and do lots of
different things to try and get the
signal that you want out of a signal
that you have or pull out the signal
that's there so just a brief review an F
IR filter is what's called a finite
impulse response filter and basically an
average a window to average is a finite
impulse response filter with all the
same coefficients so it's it's not the
signal processing people have different
names for them but they are very similar
and if I are stable it has a nice
characteristic called linear phase
response there's also another kind of
filter called an impulse an infinite
impulse response one thing that's about
these that's not so nice is that they
can be unstable if you can be careful
and make it stable when you design it
but
and it has non linear phase response
well why would you want to use that it
turns out you can get much better
filtering characteristics much better
cut off of the frequencies you don't
want in your signal if you use an IR and
has less coefficients that you have to
use less multiplications and hardware
engineers love that because they only
have a fixed number of multiplication
factors than the hardware but that's
that so when you filter e signals what
do you do do you roll your own it's only
a convolution is just a multiplication
in some editions well sighs signal comes
to your rescue it's been there and done
all of that it has a very MATLAB look
and feel which was nice for me because I
was translating these algorithms from
MATLAB you have generic filtering
functions you have filter filter design
algorithms you could be very specific
and very clear about what your filter
does what's the cutoff frequency and
when you apply the filter some of the
things you have to watch out for our
transients a start-up transient when you
first start the filter you can get a big
spike just because the filter is filling
in and one way to handle that is you can
subtract the first get rid of a DC
offset you can subtract and get get rid
of that you can also try something that
is implemented in sight pi and that's
called filt filt which actually does a
forward filtering and then reverses the
data and does a backward filtering so
this is called a non-causal filter and
it's very useful but you have to have
the data all the data you can't do this
real time so you can't do it only on a
single pass you have two tabs of all day
data in front of you before you can do
this there are problems with filter filt
I've noticed be really interested to
talk to people about it there's very
very small numerical differences between
the output of filled filled in scifi and
MATLAB there's also actual differences
between architectures in a Python
implementation on one architecture in
another so the interest to talk to
people about that well let's get back to
a in algorithm let's calculate the tilt
the tilt is a measure of the posture and
here's an algorithm on the left it's a
lot but a loop has reappeared
unfortunately this was a
translation of the seat code and it
looks a little heavy there's a loop
there's a bunch of if statements but you
could translate that and it's also
because of the loop it's very slow we're
doing each element as we as we see it
let's take it into numpy do that vector
eyes all our operations use the the full
functionality of numpy to clearly
specify what we're doing we're
subtracting something from the whole
array we r multiplied we're calibrating
or scaling it we're clipping the value
to a certain range and then we're
converting all that two degrees so the
right implementation is much more
readable it's much more succinctness
pressive and it's also much faster in
fact it's 137 times speedup relative to
the one on the left well let's take it
more difficult algorithm the heart rate
so it's much more challenging algorithm
on the left you see an example a very
this is actual real data but it's an
example of a normal sinus rhythm ECG you
have all of those different p q r s and
T those are defined points on an ECG
waveform and the heart rate is defined
as the interval between the are two are
peaks the RP defines when the ventricles
contract and push blood out of the heart
and the P wave and the T wave defined
when other things are filling one other
electrical signals are going through the
heart so our goal is to measure the
positions of the art our Peaks well the
standard the gold standard algorithm for
this in it's been around since 1985 you
could google it there all kinds of
implementations out there even MATLAB
implementations and it's very easy to
find written up by two two guys who
implemented it in an embedded context
but it's the gold standard seek
quote-unquote gold standard for these
normal sinus rhythm heart rates and it's
since it was embedded it's used in a lot
of devices now in fact most of the
devices that do heart rate might be
using this if they're using it off and
egcg you've got an outline of the basic
algorithm there and we applied this to
we we could
this directly into our system and it
works pretty well 44 these signals but
filters matter so as part of that part
of the pan Tompkins one of the things
that you I go back one of the things you
first do is you have a bandpass filter
which you filter on the low end and you
filter on the high end so you eliminate
frequencies below five Hertz and you
eliminate frequencies above 15 Hertz so
you capture the heart rate but eliminate
other things like noise but when we use
that bandpass filter we used an IR
filter and we notice some differences
some do the syfy fulfilled
inconsistencies but we also notice some
some of the heart rates were being
missed and we didn't like that so the IR
filter also does it distorts the signal
we didn't like that distortion because
you can actually pull out if you have a
nice clean ECG waveform you can actually
pull out the respiration rate from a low
frequency look at the the there's a
there's a low frequency respiration rate
riding on top of the ECG waveform and
when you distort the waveform that goes
so you need you need to get rid of that
so what we do we try to Savitsky goal a
filter which is actually built designed
by two analytical chemists way back in
nineteen sixty four I don't know how the
analytical chemist got into the room but
this this is a very nice filter it's
called a filter but it's really a bitter
it's not it doesn't filter in this
classic sense and we applied that but
what do we get we have the savitsky
google a filter give it the raw ECG and
our results we found one peak we
expected 814 peaks for this one
particular segment of the waveform on
the right you see the waveform the
circles identify the peaks we expected
and the arrows point to one dot that we
found which isn't even a peek so which
sucks but if you dig into it a little
bit more we we forgot that inside the
ECG inside the pan tompkins there's a
differentiating filter that wasn't that
was giving rise to a huge transient and
that huge transient was causing us to
miss every one of these Peaks because
the only thing that it found was that
first beak and it could never get us its
threshold down it's sort of an adaptive
threshold
find these other Peaks the peak finder
found it but then the adaptive threshold
decided those Peaks weren't really peaks
so the the there is the the solution to
this is to either go back to the the pan
Tompkins filter the ECG bandpass filter
or you define another filter so you can
get rid of that DC component so you can
get rid of this large startup transient
so we do that but that's a nice egt
that's an easy ECG that's a normal
healthy ECG that's that standard but
when you start looking at really see
geez things get really really confusing
very quickly so on the top left we have
a very standard ECG you don't really see
the P wave too much it's a little bit
noisier but you see the QRS complex in
the T wave at on the other side then
right after that in the Box you see this
huge spiky behavior this and that is
anybody anybody know what that is need
any doctors in the house let's call it a
premature ventricular contraction
contraction so also PVC for short and
what's happening is there's a lectric
olimp ulsan the heart / it's a mistake
in a hard saying ventricles contract now
there's no blood in the heart yet the
heart hasn't recovered it just
prematurely contracts and pushes out and
you get this huge fight but it's not a
heartbeat so you have to watch those
things and doctors are really interested
in these heart rate because this isn't
the only one there are several other
diseases buzzers of these that can occur
in an ECG waveform in the top right all
right let's go down to the top left I'm
sorry bottom left so you see a different
thing you don't even see an ECG or a QRS
complex there at all one that looks like
it might look like a [ __ ] us QRS complex
isn't because it's it's too short it
doesn't respond that fast the heart
doesn't respond that fast this is from a
heart failure patient that's actually
wearing a pacemaker so the up down
before each really big downward Valley
is the pacemaker going off and telling
the heart to contract
but it has no normal heart rate
heartbeat and if you throw this ECG into
a pan tompkins algorithm you get
horrible results because the pan
Tompkins algorithm is biased toward the
ECG Peaks not the ECG valleys so you
have to do a little bit more to get that
on the upper right you see a pattern
that hopefully you can see that but you
get this normal regular heartbeat and
then you get these three beat patterns
to very close and then one for their way
to very close and one further away this
really really messes doesn't mess with
the heart rate calculation but it does
mess with something called the heart
rate variability which is also another
very interesting physiological component
so if your heart rate variability
changes doctors are very interested in
that and the last one on the bottom it's
really really hard to see but it turns
out that it's very similar to the other
one but it has a almost a double you
like waveform so there are almost three
or four bet down going Peaks so figuring
out which is which or which one to
decide upon in an algorithm ways is
difficult well as we all know data so
we've got all this data we've got all
these vital signs we've got everything
you know that we can extract from the
from the filtered algorithm but it's not
information and we want we want
information that we can feed to doctors
right we want to reduce this information
so they can have something they can look
at to see which patient is is our wish
patients are doing well or not so the
last part let's go back to our our
algorithms again our machine learning
algorithms and what do we do well we
build a model of a particular subject we
collect a reference set for each subject
for of a representative sample of their
their vital signs that are coming in
from the device and that represents sort
of their baseline physiology we use that
model then to predict as more data comes
in we use that baseline to predict what
their vitals might be expected to be we
compare those expectations just do as a
residual analysis and we do some
statistical analysis to compare those
expectations
the incoming data to see if there are
any differences so on the right you see
a little bit older version of our
website the blue are the vital signs we
have heart rate on the top respiration
rate in the middle pulse transit time
which is blood pressure proxy in the
third and spo2 which is blood
oxygenation and the yellow are the
estimates so everything is lining up
every all the vital is coming in and the
predictions are right on top of one
another and we would say that this
person looks identical to their
reference set it looks identical to a
previous version of themselves well we
can also look at different cases where
maybe over time the doctor can see or
the the estimating engine predicts at
the bottom the spo2 for these other
vital signs is predicted to be this
value but we're seeing this value so we
like to pick that up and we we generate
some alert in the red there that's
dealer we don't we don't buzz and he's
it buzz anyone or anything like that but
we just say this person needs to be
checked on okay it would still have a
little time so the one of the things
that so that was sigh pie and numpy
solved a lot of problems main thing made
the code a lot more a lot easier to
understand and sci-fi help with the
filtering and it was pretty much done
but then I then at one point I picked up
a book West McKinney's book on pandas
and that really changed a lot of things
for me it really helped out change my
life because there were a lot of
problems I was struggling with one of
the problems was I had to select a
subset of variables using modeling
sometimes I wanted to use the heart rate
and respiration rate and pulse transit
times sometimes I didn't I wanted to use
another set or a different set another
problem was that I needed to calculate
time boxed averages of things and a
third problem was that if samples are
missing I want it to put in for high
frequency data I wanted to put in
samples to normalize the sample rate
because we could have Bluetooth dropouts
right and so I needed to have this
for that so here are some of the
solutions the number i mean numpy can
handle these things and did but the code
felt literary clunky so the numpy
solution you can index using a list so
but the problem with that is you have to
maintain a list of where all those
things are the heart rates in this
column the you have to maintain a map
and you always have to go back to that
map and get the values from it it's not
intuitive and it's not real easy to read
pandas solution obviously provides an
ability to create a data frame with
named columns so you can just index by
named columns now that's that actually
that data that that won't work you have
to do is the i-x if you have experience
with pandas they should have checked
that last night but i wrote that up it's
intuitive and clean because it tells
exactly what you're supposed to what you
want to do but there is a slight hidden
costs to using data frames in this way
at least for my application because i
have a lot of data I've like many many
rows of observations at different times
but I want to use different samples at
different different different vital
signs are different columns from that in
order to iterate through a pandas
dataframe you have to call something
called it arose and that's really causes
a slow down because you're up every time
you go back to a knitter oh it creates a
series and gives that back to you so you
pay the cost it's not a huge cost but it
is a cost but so you pay a cost but you
get something back because it's more
intuitive it's more expressive numpy
solution for the date-time okay so
here's your quiz this is the only part
what date time is that that's UNIX
seconds you know so it's it's not human
readable right you can't just look at
that say oh yeah well that's then that's
this time right you can obviously look
it up and you can go go to your ipython
and calculate what it is but the best
thing about one of the best things I
think about pandas is that it provides a
ton of really really useful values re
useful functions and time series index
so if you haven't ever looked into the
time series functionality of pandas I
encourage you to do that because he
solved a lot of problems that come up a
lot and it's it's almost better than
using it's much better than I think then
using the date-time functionality in
normal Python but it provides you human
readable times it also allows you to
create an index for your data frame that
is human readable timestamps and when
you have those timestamps as an index
you could say okay give me the data
between this time and this time give me
the data between this time and this time
and you can quickly create time periods
or our date ranges he calls them in
pandas would say every minute you know
and on the minute I want these or every
every 15 seconds or every hour so you
can quickly create those those blocks of
time and get the data out from that
pandas dataframe exactly what you want
and since you have the the column names
you can go and get those as well well
thank you for your time I think I think
I just hit it any questions
oh yeah sorry
we we measure heartbeat every time we
can get it so we have a beat to be we
have different sampling sets so we we
measure heart read as much as we can and
we get a beat to beat set which can
become it in at any time that we have
data but then we can reduce that what we
do is reduce that set to different
different longer term sampling sets like
minute averages and quarter minute
averages so there may be a minute that
we don't have any heart rates and so we
would just get no value for that and we
may have a minute that we have many many
heart rates so we try to we try to get
as much data as we can from that but
there's going to be missing how do we
handle missing data that's the question
so what we do and we handle missing data
you mean in the vibe in the features in
missing data in missing data the way we
handle it is we in in a bio signal sense
when we get missing data what we do is
we store nant and store values that are
the maximum for that number type so if
if it stored as an n64 we store the
maximum value and then we pull that out
later that's just a purely storage
consideration so we can store that data
without storing timestamps with it for
features what we do is we also store
values as Nan's if we don't have an
observation for that Minotaur for that
particular time then we store an and
value then we make sure our our summary
functions which calculate the minute
heart rate and other summary functions
are sensitive to the fact that Nan's can
be in the set if there are Nan's if it's
all Nan's it prints out an and it
doesn't display if there are enough that
gives us an average value we get that
value so that it other questions
okay thank you oh you have another
question good yeah yeah yeah
it depends on that really it depends on
the device that we're getting the data
from so our device the device that we
originally started out with the one I
described getting data off of we had
about I'd say nine different discrete
signals that were bio signals that were
sampled at at high rates for for other
devices that are coming on the market
they will only have they'll have less
than that they'll have maybe three or
four sofort I'm sorry we can merge that
information together but typically a
patient or a subject will only wear one
particular device they won't we so a
subject will wear one device and then we
try and merge that information in into
into there so well we have extractors
that work with each particular device
because some devices create a signal
some devices give us a signal that is a
what's called photo plasma graffia chiz
a measure of how fast the the heart
pulse gets from say your chest up to
your forehead or some other extremity
and so it's a measure of blood pressure
other devices don't do that okay so if
you don't have that facility you don't
have the ability to extract a pulse
transit time from that so if that data
stream doesn't have it then we won't be
able to use that information
we have we do look at merging streams
like from say we the question is do you
look at merging streams from historical
data medical records these sorts of
things so we do look at merging data we
have have looked into it we have a we
have a an API that we push data into our
system with we have different clients
that allow us to push data into that we
have a java client a Python client so
forth so we have the ability to push
data in from different sources the time
stamping becomes an issue obviously you
want to make sure everything is
time-stamped very accurately so that you
can cross-correlate everything but we we
were looking mostly at emerging data
from things like bluetooth scales and
these sorts of things medical records
were we do have the in our website we
have an ability to sort of manage
medical records manage things like
follow-ups and patient interactions and
these sorts of things and pull data from
EMR databases and stuff like that but we
were just at the cusp of you know trying
to get some of that external data into
our system other questions okay thank
you